[Music]
a sing-along opposite parliament with
some cabinet members competing to
replace the prime minister following
mass resignations within conservative
ranks some are wondering who's really
running the country
but inside the comments boris johnson
insisted he'd be leaving with no regrets
mr speaker and i'm also proud of the
leadership that i have given and i will
be leaving mr speaker
i will be leaving soon with
my head held high
we have a new chancellor accepted a job
from the prime minister on wednesday
afternoon and then told him to quit on
thursday morning
and the new education secretary whose
junior ministers have literally been
giving the middle finger to the public
it is truly the country's loss that they
will only be in post for a few weeks
i can now announce the result
of the ballad held
this afternoon on wednesday initial
voting by conservative mps narrowed the
field of would-be leaders to six names
someone gaining momentum is penny
mordant a trade minister and former
defense secretary she's far from a
household name but tipped as the party
activist's favorite if we do not win the
next general election all those
opportunities and the vision that the
british people had from us leaving the
european union will not be realized we
must win that election
i am your best shot at winning that
nation i am the candidate that labor
fear
but the newly appointed chancellor nadim
zahawi is eliminated as well as former
foreign secretary jeremy hunt
the result of the final stage of voting
among fewer than 200 000 conservative
members is expected by the 5th of
september
so we're slightly closer to knowing who
will be the next conservative party
leader and hence prime minister once
we're down to the last two candidates
it's up to the party membership most of
them over the age of 55 two-thirds of
them men whoever they choose will face
huge challenges not only in reviving the
party's fortunes but in dealing with
multiple crises this winter nadine
barbara al jazeera london